gibt es ein klingball in der Überleitung
zu Herrn Katzenberg in der Ampel
wenigstens noch Einigkeit in Sachen
Ukraine
ja was die Unterstützung angeht was also
haben wir jetzt ja erst vor kurzem
gesehen kurz vor dem selenski-besuch
Paket
2,7 Milliarden noch mal größte
militärische Unterstützungspaket für die
Ukraine und ich fand diesen Besuch von
selenski hier in Berlin sehr
wertschätzend und es hat gezeigt dass
das Deutschland und das hat er auch
gesagt wirklich ein verlässlicher
Partner der Ukraine ist und da sehe ich
über die Ampel hinaus
ich nehme die Union jetzt explizit doch
mit rein sich keine Risse in der
Demokratischen Mitte hier in Deutschland
was die Unterstützung der Ukraine angeht
aber natürlich müssen wir doch jeden Tag
bewerben weil die Gefahren natürlich bei
den Populisten die gerade sagen warum
Geld für die Ukraine
das das auch da stimmt schon aber dass
die Unterstützung da ist und dass sie
weitergehen muss da gibt's keine Zeit
okay Jonas Katzenberg ist bei uns äh die
noch mal ganz herzlich begrüße und der
als
Soldat in der Ukraine gekämpft hat
hatten sehr bewegendes Buch darüber
geschrieben und es gibt gerade dieser
Tage Katzenberg und ich habe mich
gefragt wie sie ihn dabei geht aus
bachmut
bin ich sage spektakuläre Bilders dass
das falsche Wort furchtbare Bilder
auf den zu sehen ist was aus dieser
Stadt geworden ist die Schlachtung
bachmund gilt als längste und
verlustreichste dieses russischen
Angriffskrieges hatte glaube ich mal
sechs 70.000 Einwohner die Stadt heute
sieht es dort ungefähr so aus sie selber
haben dort auch gekämpft im Juli 2022
also praktisch letzten Sommer und haben
die Stadt so schreiben Sie noch relativ
unversehrt erlebt das geht ihn durch den
Kopf wenn sie das hier sehen
das gibt einem so denken wofür man
letztendlich in den Krieg gegangen ist
ich muss sie leider korrigieren ich habe
in bachmut selber Gott sei Dank nicht
gekämpft
mein Kampfgebiet war hier und später
Herr Sonne aber stimmt ich habe die
Stadt noch
deutlich anders
aber sie haben sie gesehen ne dass das
meinte ich ja sie haben sie gesehen
nicht dort gekämpft aber gesehen sie
haben die Stadt erlebt sozusagen das
heißt da waren auch noch die meisten
Bewohner dieser Stadt da als sie dort
waren ja ja es war
tatsächlich deutlich besser was auch die
Zivilisten anging als zum Beispiel noch
im März im Kiew oder in
Frühsommer im späten ja Rohling in
Nikola live okay und und können Sie uns
das mal versuchen zu erklären bachmutig
meine 70.000 Einwohner eine unfassbares
Gemetzel sind tausende zehntausende
Soldaten gestorben auf beiden Seiten
übrigens die längste die blutigste
Schlacht in diesem Krieg warum war diese
Kleinstadt in der Ostukraine plötzlich
so wichtig und es ist offenbar nach wie
vor
tja bachmut hat seine Wichtigkeit
erlangt als die gegneroffensive der
Ukraine noch nicht angegangen ist als
tatsächlich die Haupt die
Hauptverteidigungslinie der Ukraine
zwischen sowianz bist kann man Torsten
gelaufen ist und von da wäre bachmut
praktisch
das Tor in den Don Bass das Tor für die
komplette Eroberung in den Don Bass und
was man sich danach erhofft hat nachdem
die Verteidigungslinie kann man Tors
gebrochen ist
die die flutere sich öffnen bis zum bist
du lieber
so
diese strategische Bedeutung hat die
Stadt ziemlich früh durch diese
Gegenoffensive in hakiv verloren
das Problem ist dass bis dahin die Stadt
schon einen gewissen Symbol Charakter
hatte die selbst während der
Gegenoffensive war dort immer
russische Offensive und dort auch immer
ein ein Beispiel für für russische
Eroberung zu sehen zumindest für das das
Publikum in Russland
und gleichzeitig man auch was die
Politik angeht was die die Politik
innerhalb der russischen Armee angeht
ist bachmut wie man sieht für pregorien
aber auch für Wagner genau der
finanziell von von Wagner aber auch von
Scholl gut der zu dem Zeitpunkt
genau neue ernannt wurde
das ist ein ein politisches Ziel ein
politischer Preis das von von hoher
Symbolik vielleicht kann die Regie das
einmal kurz zu spielen es gibt
beeindruckende dieser Tage gerade
häufiger gesehen vorher nachher Bilder
wo man einfach über Satellitenaufnahmen
nachvollziehen kann was aus einzelnen
Straßenzügen aus einzelnen vierteln in
dieser Stadt geworden ist wie das vorher
aussah und wie das heute aussah
absolut zerstört wohl immer
wie haben sie das erlebt Katzenberg habe
ich mich gefragt diese
diese
unvorstellbare Bereitschaft zu
Eskalation und zu Gewalt vergangene
Woche mit Boris schomatzki hier darüber
gesprochen das sind russischer
Schriftsteller der sehr eindringlich
erklärt
wie tief verankert in der russischen
Gesellschaft diese Bereitschaft zu
Gewalt ist die eine Spur führt in die
Familien alle 40 bis 60 Minuten mit den
Russland eine Frau zu Tode geprügelt und
jeder dritte russische Mann war im
Gefängnis oder ist im Gefängnis dahin
führt sozusagen die zweite Spur Menschen
werden systematisch gedemütigt gefoltert
vergewaltigt um um genau diese Gewalt in
diese Gesellschaft hinein zu tragen und
er sagt er selbst wenn du dich wärst du
kannst dich dem nicht entziehen wie
haben sie das erlebt
das würde gut zu dem passen was ich
einerseits durch
Russen in meinem meinem Umfeld
mitbekommen habe aber auch
zum Beispiel ich kenne das aus anderen
so wird Armeen damals in in Afghanistan
war es so wir hatten
Unterstützungskräfte aus Armenien und
Georgien
die ebenfalls aus diesem sowjetischen
sowjetischen Militär Tradition kommen
und dort war es üblich das kam dann vor
dass wenn ein kontingenzwechsel kam dass
die neuen frischen Soldaten dann von den
alten Veteranen vergewaltigt worden
ihre Geschichte Herr Katzenberg warum
haben Sie das gemacht warum haben Sie
sich entschlossen für die ukrainische
Armee zu kämpfen ich weiß nicht ob ich
das richtig im Kopf habe aber ihre
Eltern haben sie sie kommen aus dem
Großraum Aachen
ihren Eltern haben Sie wie viel vorher
bescheid gesagt wo sie hinfahren
ich stand
mit den Koffern im Schlafzimmer eines
Sonntags morgens abgesagt
ich gehe jetzt
die durch den Rückweg durch die Ukraine
ich weiß nicht wann ich zurück bin das
war dann was war hart für sie aber es
war reiner Selbstschutz weil ich genau
wusste dass wenn ich den jetzt
sage sobald es ein trockenen Tüchern ist
dass ich keine ruhige Minute mehr habe
bis ich letztendlich ins Auto steige
ihre Mutter macht beruflich was
dieses Ärztin ihr Vater Polizist
noch mal die Frage was war Ihre
Motivation also keine weil das Ding weil
Sohn als Berufssoldaten hätte ich das
irgendwie noch nachvollziehen können
weil man eher aus einer militärischen
Tradition kommt sie nicht ich komme aus
der dem kompletten Gegenteil also
Militär war nie till niemals
thematisiert worden meine Mutter hat
absolut nichts mit Waffen am Hut mein
Vater
ja nur durch die durch den Beruf
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht woher es kam ich war
immer vom Militär fasziniert weil
deswegen auch
gerne zur Bundeswehr gegangen lange Zeit
aber
tatsächlich in die Ukraine zu gehen um
zu kämpfen das hat immer zwei zwei
Hauptkomponenten für mich einerseits war
es eine persönliche Komponente dass ich
als Soldat das Gelernte irgendwo auch
anwenden will
und dass ich als Soldat das das auch
selbst im Gefecht so schwer es auch
nachzuvollziehen ist abbilden möchte
aber ich wäre natürlich jetzt nicht auf
russischer Seite dahin gegangen ich wäre
auch nicht in irgendeinen anderen
Konflikt gott weiß wohin gegangen und
ich wollte in die Ukraine weil mich das
Leid der Ukraine irgendwo getroffen hat
weil mich dieser diese Unrechtmäßigkeit
dieses Angriffskrieges getroffen hat
weil mich aber auch die
die mangelnde Unterstützung des Westens
und vor allem von Deutschland damals in
dieser Phase ähm betroffen hatte ich
erinnere mich an eine Szene aus aus
Aachen er von von der
Oberbürgermeisterin die
vor zwei Wochen oder vor einer Woche
jetzt silenski selber empfangen hat die
damals sagte karlspreisten genau die die
damals sagte am 25 26 Februar
nachdem russische Cruise Miss als
bereits in in ukrainische Häuserblocks
eingeschlagen sind man müsste weiter mit
den Waffen des Friedens und des Dialogs
kämpfen und das war für mich so
unverständlich das ist das dass der
Tropfen war der das passt für mich zu
überlaufen gebracht hat okay
wie geht sowas es gibt viele Geschichten
von von von eben nicht Ukrainern sollten
an die dann dorthin sind wo meldet man
sich an wo wird man dann eingesetzt und
wie läuft das dann ab also selten habe
ich eine Ukraine zumindest selber nicht
getroffen wir waren nicht wenn sie jetzt
so ja okay okay gut aber die rechtliche
Lage ist wir sind keine sollten reguläre
Kräfte der Armee beziehungsweise des
Geheimdienstes
am Anfang war das tatsächlich wieder
wilde Westen wie der wilde Osten also
ich bin ins Konsulat gegangen hat gesagt
hör mal ich möchte kämpfen habe meine
gesamten Papiere mitgebracht die sagen
ja brauchst du nicht gib uns deinen
Namen deine deine Personalausweis haben
die mir eine Adresse gegeben von der
Tankstelle irgendwo in jaworld in blast
und sagt ja meld dich da hier ist eine
Telefonnummer die anrufen kannst und
mittlerweile mittlerweile ist es anders
mittlerweile ist nicht Strukturen
gefestigt aber damals war das wirklich
einfach so durch
ja und sie hätten sein können wer sie
wollen und die hätten sie genommen ja
es gab also hat immer hat immer
überhaupt das gäbe irgendwelche
background checks die gibt es jetzt
vielleicht auch zu meiner Zeit nicht
wo war ihr erster Einsatzort was waren
das für Umstände ich habe so einen Satz
im Kopf wo sie schreiben natürlich hat
man unfassbar Schiss und zwar so lange
bis man dann dort steht und es geht
wirklich los dann wird das auf
genau also mein erster richtiger
Einsatzort meine erste Mission war um
kieferung in ihr PIN und später in
Botschaft ich war dort Gruppenführer der
der Spezialkräfte der internation und
ähm ja es ist es ist genau wie
wir es gesagt haben wenn man dann auf
dem Weg ins Gefecht ist und man weiß
dass man dort auf Feind treffen wird
dann dann macht man sich natürlich
Gedanken man denkt an all die die die
glorreichen Dinge würden vielleicht ja
die tollen Dinge vielleicht erleben kann
aber auch natürlich wie schnell es im
Krieg gehen kann das
da hinten vielleicht eine Mine liegt und
ich gleich einfach tot bin und wenn man
da rein fährt hoffentlich fahren wir
nicht auf eine Mine ja oder da sitzt
irgendwann mit einem
Scharfschützengewehr oder hinter der
nächsten Häuserwand steht ein Panzer und
dann dann war es das einfach und diese
das ist so ein Wechselspiel was im Kopf
vorgeht ne und das hört in dem Moment
auf wo man im Gefecht
ist wenn die ersten Kugeln fliegen egal
ob das die gegnerischen oder die eigenen
sind dann dann ist das vorbei dann ist
man einfach nur noch da und funktioniert
und ich habe selber gemerkt für mich das
hört nicht auf bis man irgendwie einen
einen
Disconnect hat einen richtigen
disconnect der einem aus diesem
Kampfmodus rausreißt ähm
sie haben meine Narbe ne am Kopf ja sie
sind selber schwer verletzt worden da
sieht man das auch
von einer Drohne und sie sie beschreiben
das auch im Buch und sagen das ist der
Punkt an dem du merkst es ist dann doch
ein moderner Krieg weil es geht nur noch
oder fast ausschließlich es geht um
Drohnen immer wieder Drohnen die Drohnen
sind das Dinge überhaupt warum ist das
passiert ja also der Drohne das war
tatsächlich
eine ein kleiner Quadcopter den sich
hierzu zu Lande jeder besorgen kann da
war eine kleine Handgranate dran
vielleicht was auch eine
infanteriegranate ich weiß es nicht und
mit Treaty printed mit 3D gedruckten
abwurfgeräten sind über uns drüber
geflogen als weil es unser Fahrzeug
versagt hat wir saßen im Graben drin und
die hat sich in dem Moment einfach nicht
ausgesucht ich habe mich auf dem Boden
geschmissen sie hat die vielleicht ein
zwei Handbreit neben mir aufschlagen
lassen und
das Ergebnis sehen Sie
und dann was
tja
ich habe keine Schmerzen gespürt ich es
hat sich angefühlt als ob jemand gegen
den Kopf getreten hat ich war erstmal
wie benebelt aber irgendwie wie gesagt
ich war noch in diesem in diesem Modus
drin ist relativ schnell
ähm habe ich einfach nur noch
funktioniert ich habe meine Kameraden
bescheid gesagt ähm ich habe einen
turnicket rausgeholt für meinen
Kameraden ich habe guckt dass das meine
Finger noch dran sind ich gucke dass
meine meine dass ich noch sehen kann ich
habe ähm
gesucht genau das habe ich eine Sache
die ich tatsächlich gar nicht gemerkt
habe bis ich wirklich ins Krankenhaus
gekommen bin bis ich aufgewacht bin
dass ich einen Splitter im Auge hatte
ich dachte mir wäre einfach nur ein
bisschen Blut ins Auge gelaufen und
alles ist gut
tja und dann hat
Schurig mir dass das turnical angelegt
und dann habe ich auch wieder Schmerz
gespürt
ich habe tatsächlich bis
bis letzte Nacht gar nicht festgestellt
wie wie gefährlich das eigentlich war
ich habe letzte Nacht von meiner
Freundin gesagt bekommen dass das ich
ein ein Gehirnblutung hatte und dass der
Doktor zu ihr wohl gesagt hätte als sie
mich besucht hat im Krankenhaus dass die
meisten die meisten Jungen mit meinen
Verletzungen gar nicht das Business
Krankenhaus schaffen
ich habe kürzlich in Odessa Soldaten
getroffen schwer verwundete Leute die in
einer Schönheitsklinik völlig verrückt
aber der plastische Chirurgen sind sehr
wertvoll in Kriegszeiten Menschen ohne
Unterkiefer das halbe Gesicht
weggesprengt das wird dann wieder
irgendwie rekonstruiert und so weiter
und man sieht was dieser Krieg mit
diesen Männern macht
was hat das mit ihm gemacht also diese
sie sagten gerade Botschaft das heißt
das was dort passiert ist das haben sie
mit eigenen Augen gesehen
ja ich habe das gesehen was letztendlich
davon übrig geblieben ist
das war tatsächlich für mich und für
viele in meinem Team auch die erste
Begegnung mit dem Krieg mit den den
Seiten die man vielleicht nicht überall
sieht
die im Fernsehen normalerweise
ausgeblendet werden
ist bei Zivilisten ist es was anderes
also bei bei Soldaten ist es eine Sache
bei Zivilisten ist was anderes und vor
allem die Art und Weise wie
wie dort getötet wurde in irpen waren es
meistens verstreute Granat Treffer
Artillerie oder Sprengfallen die
irgendeine Arme Babuschka dann aus
Versehen reingelaufen ist aber in guter
haben wir wirklich tatsächlich wir haben
Kinder gesehen wir haben werden Leute
mit
Kopfschüssen am Straßenrand gesehen
das ist anders das das ist noch mal was
komplett anderes als die
die Berge von Leichen die man manchmal
in manchen Kriegszonen findet
nein ist
es trifft einen anders man
denkt nur mal ganz anders darüber nach
klar die
natürlich ist nicht jeder Soldat da weil
er Bock auf Krieg hat
aber grundsätzlich
ist das Töten von Soldaten eine eine
Notwendigkeit eine grausame
Notwendigkeit aber was da ein guter
passiert weil das war das war keine
Notwendigkeit
diese russische Armee ist ich habe das
von zitiert sie sagen da war nichts zu
erkennen keine Taktik kann gar nichts
einfach nur Zerstörungswut Rumgeballer
kaputt machen
das kam ein manchmal so vor ich kann
natürlich nicht genau sagen wie die
Russen vorgegangen sind aber was ich
gemerkt habe ist erstmal wie wie
Inkompetenz sie vorgegangen sind aber
gleichzeitig wie wie zerstörerisch
also es werden es werden völlig
völlig
unvernünftige Angriffe gestartet
und die werden dann durch durch Arterie
gerade gerückt
wo haben sie das erlebt was für
Situationen Kiew in earpin zum Beispiel
wir hatten keinen Feind Kontakt werden
keinen einzelnen Russen gesehen aber wir
standen wirklich zwei Tage und zwei
Nächte unter Artillerie Beschuss
und
allein auf dem Weg in unseren OP sind
wir über so viele
Leichen von von Männern von Frauen
Hunden und Katzen gestolpert die die
einfach
niedergemäht wurden ja
[Musik]
die erste Leiche die ich gesehen habe
das war eine alte Frau die gerade vom
Wasser holen gekommen ist die lag dann
damit ihrem Rollator und die
Wasserflaschen lagen verstreut auf der
Straße
so
blinde Artillerie blindesartiller
haben sie selber auch Menschen töten
müssen
darüber rede ich nicht
warum nicht das ist das ist persönlich
das ist etwas das da reden nur die Leute
richtig mit den Leuten darüber die
wirklich dabei gewesen sind also auch
mit Kameraden aus der Bundeswehr jetzt
die nicht selber da gewesen sind rede
ich da nicht drüber das ist was für mich
persönlich
und die meine Eingeweihten Kameraden
jetzt ist da dieser Gegner und ich kann
mir das vorstellen wenn man dann
beschossen wird so wie Sie es gerade
beschrieben haben dann ist der Reflex
okay den Zahlen wir es Heim denkt man
trotzdem manchmal darüber nach dass die
auf der anderen Seite möglicherweise
gezwungen worden sind
auch wenn sie ja freiwillig da
reingegangen sind auf jeden Fall das vor
allem ist wohl ein größeres Thema vor
allem als die offizielle Mobilmachung
empfohlen wurde aber ich weiß auch dass
schon vorher Leute
unfreiwillig in Russland eingezogen
wurden
natürlich ist dann das bewusst und
natürlich
mir persönlich war es als als Führer
einer freiwilligeneinheit ich hätte
keine ukrainischen Kameraden in meiner
eigenen Einheit
überall her viele Israelis sehr viele
Georgier Weißrussen Polen deutsche
Briten und und Amerikaner aber auch
Leute viel aus aus Südamerika aber auch
Japaner Koreaner
richtig die ganze Welt die wie wie wie
viel Geld gibt es dafür
also man kriegt das das gleiche auf
Papier kriegt man das gleiche Gehalt wie
wie jeder andere Ukrainisch Soldat das
ist ein das sind
15 320.000 riefner das waren zu meiner
Zeit
500 Euro
und dazu kriegt man denn
angeblich gibt es normalerweise noch
eine eine Prämie wenn man im Kampf
selber ist kriegt man dann pro Monat
noch mal
100.000 Rechner mittlerweile sind das
sind das
3000 2000 Euro im Monat da ist aber die
Sache dann hat man
Kommandeure die ist eins dies
einbehalten oder Leute den halt keinen
Bock haben die extra den extra
Papierkram der äh dafür zu machen okay
für meine für meine 282 Tage fast 11
Monate da unten
oder zehn Monate und unten und 12000 €
verdient also
hätte ich in Deutschland deutlich ja
wenn ich durch besser
wir haben gerade über die Gewalt auf der
russischen Seite gesprochen es läuft
leider auch ein bisschen die Zeit davon
aber trotzdem noch die letzte Frage über
russische Kriegsverbrechen haben wir
viel gehört und gesprochen hier aber es
gibt auch ukrainische Kriegsverbrechen
haben ja
habe ich persönlich
persönlich miterlebt gesehen gelebt
das war auch so eine der
Hauptgründe für das Buch weil das so ein
weil ich Dinge erlebt habe die die in
Deutschland weniger präsent sind und
weil das für mich einfach eine Chance
war
ein unverfälschten Blick auf den Krieg
freizugeben und deswegen gehe ich auch
speziell auf auf ukrainische
Kriegsverbrechen wie zum Beispiel das
der Missbrauch von Schutzzeichen mit dem
Roten Kreuz
bis hin zu der der Empfang von
Kriegsgefangenen ein
sehr sie sie erzählen diese Geschichte
drei russische Kriegsgefangene
ukrainische Soldaten die gehen in einen
Wald und dann wenig später kommen die
drei Ukraine ohne die russischen
Kriegsgefangenen zurück genau man hört
drei Schüsse
kommen ohne ohne Kriegsgefangenen zurück
und das nächste was man hört zwei drei
Tage später ist das ist eine
Untersuchung gibt weil wohl vermutet
wird das Kriegsgefangene erschossen
werden was ist der Untersuchung geworden
ist weiß ich nichts von aber was richtig
zum Schluss was richtig das gemacht
worden auf jeden Fall
weil
weil ich einfach gesehen habe dass trotz
ihrer Verfehlungen und trotz der der
Kriegsverbrechen die man wenn man
ehrlicherweise leider sagen muss in
jeder Armee in jedem Konflikt vorkommen
die Ukraine trotzdem weiter unsere
Unterstützung braucht und vor allem die
Bevölkerung unsere Unterstützung braucht
gegenüber dem was die die Russen dort
dort anrichten
das habe ich in Odessa genauso gesehen
Herr Katzenberger ich danke Ihnen sehr
sehr lesenswert ihr Buch weiß dass sie
das nicht einfach oder leicht gefallen
ist deswegen großen Respekt